حيث افادت وكاله ينهاب من كوريا الجنوبيه
لم تنجح في اسقاط طائرات مسيره كوريا
الشماليه اخترقت اجواءها ونشرت وسائل
اعلام كوريا جنوبيه صورا لتحطم طائره
هجوميه خفيفه في منطقه هونج سونج اثناء
استعدادها لدعم عمليه التصدي
لمسيره تابعه لكوريا الشماليه اخترقت
المجال الجويه
طائره استطلاع جنوب كوريا الجنوبيه بعد
انتهاك المسير الكوريه الشماليه لمجالها
الجويه كما ظهرت صور للشاشات في مطار
جينبو الكوريه الجنوبي تاخر رحلات جويه
عده وكان مسؤول في وزاره النقل قد افاد
بان صول علقت رحلات المغادره لفتره وجيزه
في مطرين اثنين قرب العاصمه صول بنا ان
على طلب ان عسكري
وفي اول ردود الفعل الكوريه الجنوبيه
اعتبر مسؤول عسكريون من انتهاك اجواء
بلاده من قبل مسيرات من كونفيونغ عملا
استفزازي واضح واضاف ان الجيش الكوريه
الجنوبيه اتخذ اجراءات للرد على ذلك عبر
ارسال مقاتلات شمال حدوده العسكريه يشار
الى ان هذه هي المره الاولى منذ خمس سنوات
التي تحلق فيها طائرات مسيره كوريه شماليه
في المجال الجوي لكوريا الجنوبيه
جربي اخر تحطمت مقاتله كوريا الجنوبيه
هجوميه خفيفه من طراز كايئي واحد في
مقاطعه ويندوز سونج الشرقيه العاصمه صول
بينما تمكن الطيران من النجاه ووفقا للجيش
الكوري الجنوبي فان الطائره تسقطت بعد وقت
قصير من اقلاعها قاعده في مدينه ونجو
القريبه ولم تحدث اي اضرار في منازل
المدني